sleep sleep sleep
sleep it is a very complicated subject
falling asleep staying asleep it's
something we've all struggled with
for years i know i'm not alone
in fact a recent study done by the
national sleep foundation found over
that
half of our country has issues with
sleep i'm surprised it's that little
and it's time to break this cycle so
let's meet alicia
who came to us asking for advice roll
the tape
hey guys so i had a long day today i had
to work a double
i got home about an hour ago i'm gonna
try to get some sleep i have to be up at
six around 6 30 get the kids up
get them off to school and start my day
at work so i'm hoping that i could sleep
through the night get a good
five five and a half hours of straight
sleep uninterrupted
i woke up twice last night i didn't
actually fall asleep
until about 2 15 and i was kind of
tossing turning i was a little bit
hot and then i finally got into my sleep
and then i woke up around
four and then i dozed back off for a
minute and then was back up at about 5
45
i am pretty tired i can feel that i do
have a mild headache hopefully i'll feel
better
get some energy and move around once i
get out the shower
i'm up and now and i got my first cup of
coffee for the day
i'm feeling okay right now a little bit
sleepy but i'm just
trying to push through see what the day
brings
it's midday i feel like i'm starting to
crash i'm extremely exhausted
i think i'm gonna need another cup of
coffee to help me power through and get
through the rest of my day
i'm getting ready for bed and i am
dreading this
because i know i'm going to have to do
everything all over again tomorrow
this is an awful cycle that needs to
break
because i am so tired
alicia i am just anxious
for you alicia hi
hi how are you
[Applause]
but i'm good i'm good how long have you
been having these sleep issues
i've been having these sleep issues for
about two years you know i'm a doctor
i'm a psychologist i work in a
psychiatric hospital as well as a
correctional facility
so sleep is imperative for what i do but
sometimes i'm just so
exhausted i have migraines often so
it's just it's just horrible and i don't
understand why there are times that i
can be in bed for eight hours
and i am still exhausted once i wake up
and i just don't understand why
um alicia am i correct that you work at
rikers island
yes and how long have you worked there
for two years right around when your
sleep problem started
yes okay all right well i am not the
sleep
expert but i'm seeing uh two patterns
here that said we have a sleep expert
so i'll speak to some of those other
things but can we bring her in
yes that would be great all right alicia
let's do this all right
sleep expert dr sanuja hamilton
is here to help hi dr hamilton how are
you
i'm great so happy to be here us too
and i think that alicia's
case is sounding very specific and i
think we can attack it
what are the biggest causes of not being
able to sleep
yeah you know there are a number of
things that control our sleep
and sometimes it can be something
insignificant or temporary
or a lifestyle change that can affect
our sleep and cause a chronic persistent
problem
so allegiance she works the double shift
so now her schedule is all over the
place
and that's really important our sleep is
controlled by our circadian rhythm or
our internal clock
and it likes consistency so it's
important to have those consistent
bedtimes
if you can a lot of people have sunday
night insomnia
that's when you sleep in on your days
off or you nap all weekend long and then
when sunday night comes you've now set
the stage
uh for difficulty falling asleep for the
rest of the week
okay so for the past week dr hamilton
performed a sleep experiment
with alicia to help her examine her
sleep patterns
dr hamilton what did you find
so a couple of things for one thing she
went into rem sleep pretty quickly which
suggests either sleep deprivation or
other sleep issues you also had
less rem sleep alicia you're at about
maybe 16
when normal rem sleep is 20 to 25
and rem sleep is very important that's
our most restorative stage of sleep
so it's really important to get that rem
sleep what does she do
the first thing to do is to prioritize
your sleep you know everyone sets a
morning alarm so you're not late to work
or that important meeting
i would set a bedtime alarm and of
course
shutting down off the screens shutting
off tv shutting off the phone you know
when you watch something
at night you get lost in it or you end
up if you start scrolling you get stuck
uh scrolling forever so it distracts you
and the other important thing is the
blue wavelengths those blue lights
emitted from the screens your natural
melatonin from being secreted
alicia do you have blue light glasses
no i make some at flower eyewear and i'm
going to send you some
oh thank you so much they do make a
difference
and alicia really quick do you like your
job
i absolutely love my job i love what i
do but on top of work i'm a mother of
four
i'm a wife so you know the lack of sleep
definitely plays a major part
in my home as well and you used to
exercise i think you were in a triathlon
right
yes yes when did you stop exercising
maybe about a year and a half two years
ago when i
changed my work schedule and i started
working at this new job
did you find that you did sleep better
when you exercise can you carve that out
i mean if you're taking in
everybody's stuff where are you putting
it out
yeah absolutely right i think the
exercise would be beneficial
um it would make a huge difference it
would definitely help me sleep better
because i noticed when i was exercising
i was sleeping better
through the night and waking up with
energy and no headaches at
all so that made a huge difference
well then this is a non-negotiable you
have to
get back up on that exercise horse
absolutely i agree so now some
self-preservation get
off that phone at night put those blue
light glasses on and let's
fix this you deserve it yes thank you
yes absolutely okay sorry i got really
passionate there alicia we're gonna go
go to commercial dr hamilton is gonna
give us more
tools to help us get a good night's
sleep with some other women who are
going through the same thing and we all
deserve this
you